il y aura des actions violentes la
prédiction est de François Santoni
l'ancien leader de la kuncolta le bras
politique du FLNC affirme qu'il faut
prendre très au sérieux les menaces
d'armata Corsa le groupe séparatiste
clandestin Corse mais François Santoni
réagit également et il n'est pas le seul
à la lettre d'Ivan Colona dans laquelle
l'assassin présumé du préfet rgac clame
son innocence commentaire Juliette beau
parce qu'il s'est exprimé dans une
lettre manuscrite l'ennemi public numéro
1 provoque depuis hier de vives réaction
comme celle de l'ancien secrétaire
général d'akolta indépendista qui trouve
ce courrier misérable j'aurais préféré
pour lui qui se présente devant la
presse même de manière clandestine les
armes à la main et de se soumettre au
feu des questions quant à Jean-Pierre
Chevenement il affirme Ivan Colona est
un lâche il parle même d'un abandon de
la souveraineté nationale Charles pasquy
enfonce le clou le gouvernement a déjà
abdiqué déclare-t-il on parle du plan
Jospin il vaudrait mieux dire tout
simplement le plan des nationalistes
face à ces attaques directes sur la
projet de loi sur la Corse le
gouvernement se concentre sur l'affaire
Colona l'idéal pour lui c'est d'aller
devant le J d'instruction parce que à la
limite s'exprimer comme ça c'est c'est
presque ce présumé coupable alors qu'il
est présumé innocent il doit être jugé
par un tribunal correctionnel il se
présente vraiment qu'il se présente la
lettre d'Ant Colona donnera lieu à de
nouvelles investigations qui devraiit
alourdir le dossier d'instruction le
procès pourrait avoir lieu avant le
printemps